I'm talking to mr.
Bob cold facts who worked at the maria
quarry and also up in sydney on the pylons
during the building of the sydney harbour
bridge. Do you remember how you first got
your job. Mr folks. Yes. I was
born and educated in maria and
i went off to high school in sydney. When
i was twelve years of age and from there
on i was
a long time away from maria and very homesick
for it all the time i was working for
the irrigation commission
in griffith and i had
a very good job and i was advancing well
in the job. But i was offered the job at
maria quarry and because i was so terribly
homesick. I threw aside this permanent
job with
a great prospect and came down to work at
the meru your quarry at the end of 1924.
What was your job there at the quarry ms
twelve. I was general clark in the quarry
and my father was the timekeeper.
And what did your job entail my job
entailed the preparation of cost
records and some correspondence and
the management of some of the stores
records and all kinds of returns that the
company required weekly and anything of
a general nature that was required to be
done in the office there. How many people
worked at the quarry. Well when i was
there the maximum number was two hundred
forty. Two hundred forty
years. That was the maximum when rollman
and men were paid weekly i was paid
clerk as well. I forgot to say previously.
And the men were paid weekly and the
amount of money. The total money for the
power. All right. Approximately fifteen
hundred pounds a week was
a stable workforce of 250 or was it more
or less now that was stable at the time i
was there you know what they did the
various numbers of the various jobs. Well
there were ninety stone masons which was
of course they were the principal members
of the workforce and then of course the
requirement to get the root stone out and
then the first part of the
quarry workings. They had
a huge crashing plant where they broke up
the ground balls and converted it into
aggregate for making the concrete for the
building of the piers and the pile and.
Do you memo how many workers there were in
the quarry end of things. Well as i said
there were ninety stone
masons and i would say just
a quick guess would be up to say twelve
quarryman but then of course the auxilary
men such as quite a few labourers
powder monkey and then of course we had
a huge power house there and there were
the engineers and we had we had to
construct
a water supply for the quarry and also for
the village that was subsequently built
there for the workmen and we had
carpenters and so forth. We had. We had. A
plumber and practically
a reclassification of. Tradesmen that you
could nominate electrician. Yes you know
. Did you remember the building of the great
town america. Oh i remember that very
well they constructed sixty seven
cottages. There were about six
three room cottages and all the rest were
forum cottages and i can recollect that
we got all the hardwood timber
from mitchell brothers and
a rumour and it only cost twenty shillings
four hundred superficial feet at that
particular time. You know what happened
to those cottages after they were removed
from the. They were they were sold. I
wasn't there when they were sold but i know
that they were sold properly by auction.
And of course the terms of sale was that
the purchaser dismantle the cottage and
take it away and they were they were built
as they stood previously in many different
parts and of course the total of
the material was used to build bigger
buildings but as well as the duplication of
the buildings as they originally were as
far north as ulladulla. I've seen some
aboriginals who claim that they're living
in cottages it already in point which we
came from the bridge. I don't know. It's
quite possible. It's quite possible. Yes.
Can you remember anything else that happened
while you were at the quarry anything
particular. You know but the fatalities
for instance i can remember the first
battalion it was a man. A native of
maria called harry waters and he was
a crane chaser for travelling locomotive
steam crane and this crane had
a huge counterweight on it
and it could swing around in
a circle of 360 degrees and he was sitting
on the carriage and instead of walking
along. He's taking an easy ride on the
carriage of the crane and not observing that
this huge counterweight was swinging around
and it practically tragedies like he
was taken to the hospital but he only
survived for two or three days and the other
fatality was a quarryman called
percy poole also although
a local man from maria. He
went in to recover some tools
. In a huge crevice that had
been created from blasting out
a tremendous piece of granite and he went
into this crevice to recover some tools
and as he did so. The huge piece of granite
decided to slide and fill the crevice
up and he was crushed to death and they
were the only two fatalities that happened
. Maria quarry and i noticed their names
are recorded on the list of patel it is up
on the harbour bridge itself on the
plaque up there. That is correct and i've
checked that out in the morgue registers
and suchlike and it tallies exactly with
what what do you say yes
yes indeed. There were
a great number of scotch people there of
course imported. Being stone masons and
quarryman mainly and therefore there was
a local caledonian society and maria.
And there were functions every week
caledonian society functions and
scotch dances and the like and where
a very merry time was invariably had
by all they were certainly they merge
marvelously with their local maroon
community and they were the golden years of
merari of the cash flow and free and everyone
was happy and merry and prosperous of
the italians there. Yes i remember the
italians i can't tell you exactly the number
that they are but they are all stone masons
i'd say and they the company built them
quarters of their own and they had their
own cook there that prepared the meals for
them.